how is misogyny different than the patriarchy
and how are those different from sexism
and let's also talk about Shrek
the patriarchy women are subordinate to men
there's like a gendered hierarchy
just like how in Shrek
the fairy tale creatures are subordinate to the human like characters
misogyny is the mechanism
it's like the tools that we use to sustain the patriarchy
it's how we keep people in line in Shrek and in real life
they're using laws they're using policies to enforce this subordination
social stigma and pressures
and policing is also another mechanism
to ensure that people are acting according to their gender
or fairytale creature characterness
and sexism is the belief that is justifying the misogyny and the patriarchy
belief that ogres are just naturally smelly
they are naturally less than they naturally belong in swamps
we’re using that belief system to justify keeping them in the swamps
and treating them differently
keep in mind that the misogyny that you face as a fairy tale creature
may look very different depending on what type of fairy tale creature you are
I don't know I'm still going on with this analogy
basically women are not treated monolithically
so the type of misogyny that you face is going to look very different
if you are a white woman or a woman of color
or you have a disability
or based on your class or based on your sexual orientation
things like that
and feminism is an ideology that pursues the Equality of the sexes